>> Tucker: WHY ARE SO MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE SO ANGRY?
IT'S MOSTLY ECONOMICS.
ERIC WEINSTEIN GOT THE CORE OF
IT.
HE SAID A YOUNG BREAD WINNER
NEEDS TO BY A REASONABLY PRICED
HOME IN A DECENT TOWN WITH MANY
OPPORTUNITIES AND PROVIDE FOR A
SECOND PARENT TO STAY HOME AND
RAISE YOUNG CHILDREN.
A NATION CANNOT PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
YOUNG FOLKS TO TEND TO THE
RAISES OF KIDS, WE HAVE
PROBLEMS.
WE DO.
WE ORIGINALLY TALKED TO BRAD
WILCOX FROM THE NATIONAL
MARRIAGE PROJECTS ABOUT THIS.
>> THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
AS I WATCH THE PERENNIAL
POPULARITY OF SOCIALISM COME
BACK, PEOPLE MY AGE THINK
SOCIALISM?
REALLY?
WHAT IS THE APPEAL.
WHAT COULD BE THE APPEAL?
I SEE NUMBERS LIKE THESE AND SAY
IF WE DON'T FIX THEM, WE'LL GET
SOCIALISM.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THINGS LIKE HEALTHCARE,
EMPLOYMENT, DEBT AND THEY SEE
THE GOVERNMENT AS A GOOD PLACE
FOR THEM TO SEE GREATER SECURITY
GIVEN THE BROADER CONTEXT WE'RE
SEEING TODAY IN AMERICA.
>> I WANT TO ZERO IN ON
MARRIAGE.
I KNOW YOU FOLLOW THAT.
YOU STUDY IT CLOSELY.
MARRIAGE IS AMONG MANY OTHER
THINGS AN INDICATOR AND CAUSE OF
PROSPERITY.
MARRIED PEOPLE WITH KIDS TEND TO
BE MORE ECONOMICALLY STABLE.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO REVERSE THE
TREND THAT IS CAUSING YOUNG
PEOPLE TO DELAY OR AVOID
MARRIAGE ENTIRELY?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
COUPLE THINGS THAT WE CAN DO.
ONE THING WE CAN DO IS GET RID
OF THE MARRIAGE PENALTIES THAT
FACE YOUNGER ADULTS AND POORER
ADULTS AND THINGS LIKE MEDICAID,
THE EIPC FOOD STAMPS.
WE CAN ALSO DO MORE TO THINK
ABOUT THINGS LIKE DOING MORE
SUBSIDIZED WORKING CLASS WAGES
AND I ALSO THINK WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT THE CULTURAL CONTEST
THAT WE'RE LIVING IN.
THINK ABOUT WAYS THAT WE CAN
MAKE MARRIAGE BOTH MORE
APPEALING AND THE POP CULTURE
AND TO THINK ALSO ABOUT WAYS
THAT WE CAN DO MORE TO SPEND
TIME IN PERSON AND LESS TIME
ONLINE.
LOOKS LIKE JOHN CULTURE IS
PLAYING A BIG ROLE IN THE
RE-RITA FOR MARRIAGE AND THE
RETREAT FOR FERTILITY IN THE
U.S.
>> ALL OF US HAVE AN INTEREST IN
THIS.
MARRIED KIDS ARE NOT CALLING FOR
ANTIFA.
A COUNTRY WITH A LOT OF
UNMARRIED PEOPLE IS A VOLATILE
COUNTRY.
WHY DON'T OUR POLICY MAKERS TAKE
THIS SERIOUSLY?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK A LOT --
PEOPLE THINK OF MARRIAGE AS A
PRIVATE ISSUE AND THE GOVERNMENT
CANNOT AND SHOULDN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT MARRIAGE AND FERTILITY.
THEY DON'T SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN
OUR FAMILIES AS A LOT TO DO WITH
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IN OUR COUNTRY
MORE GENERALLY.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY.
THAT'S AN OBVIOUS POINT.
WHY ISN'T EVERYBODY SAYING THAT?
WHY DO WE IGNORE THIS AS A CAUSE
OF SOCIAL VOLATILITY?
VOLATILITY WRECKING THE COUNTRY?
WHY DOES NOBODY SAY THAT?
>> I THINK IT'S OBVIOUSLY --
THINGS RELATED TO DIVORCE AND
SINGLE PARENTING COMPETITIONS
ARE SENSITIVE FOR A LOT OF US.
WE KNOW PEOPLE HAVE BEEN IN
DIFFICULT SITUATIONS.
THERE'S A RELUCTANCE TO ENGAGE.
THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR.
WE'VE SEEN WORK AT HARVARD THAT
INDICATES WE'RE IN THE BEST
PREDICTORS OF MOBILITY FOR POOR
KIDS IN COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IS THE SHARE OF TWO
PARENTS IN A COMMUNITY.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE IT IS.